يعني انا البيت الابيض الافراج عن لاعبه
السله الامريكيه بريتني جراينر المحتجزه
في روسيا وذلك في صفقه تبادل السجناء مع
موسكو كانت السلطات الروسيه اعتقلت
غرينرفي فبراير الماضي بتهمه حيازه مخدره
نعود اذا الى احمد هزيم وران مدريد كنت
تتحدث احمد عن بول همم
ملابسات اعتقاله في الولايات في روسيا لكن
هل هناك سجناء روس اخرون باستثناء دكتور
الذي افرجت عنه السلطات الامريكيه في هذه
الصفقه صفقه بريتني جرانيت
زين يصعب تحديد ماذا كان هناك سجناء روست
تطالب بهم روسيا او يعتبر روسيا انه حكومه
او عقوبه السجل التي طبقت بحقهم هنا في
الداخل الاراضي الامريكيه عقوبه سياسيه او
عقوبه تعسفيه وعقوبه غير شرعيه والحاكم
ايضا ينطبق على الولايات المتحده واي
سجناء امريكيين لدى الروس الوحيد الذي
ترفع الولايات المتحده همم
مطالباتها بالافراج عنه
ليس واضحا واذا كان هناك مواطنين امريكيين
اخرين مسجونين في روسيا بتهم الولايات
المتحده ان هذه شو وقت سياسيه او تمت
تلفيقها سياسيا همم في النسبه للولايات
المتحده لا لا ليس هناك حتى اللحظه
الدلائل على وجود شخص او همم مسجون روسي
تطالب بموسكو مقابل الافراج وهذا ربما عقد
الصفقه روسيا تريد التعامل المثل بين في
التنفيذ اعصاب عمليه تبادل السجناء لذلك
طلبت بالافراج فقط عن
اقرت بالافراج فقط عن بريتني جرايدر مقابل
ولم تقبل بالعرض الامريكي
قد قال في تغريده على تويتر انه تحدث مع
لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتني
طائره في طريقها
الى الولايات المتحده عائده من موسكو
وزاره
الخارجات التبادل السجينين رجل الاعمال
الروسيه فيكتور بوت ولعيبه كره السله
الامريكيه بريتنير